.
DID NOT REALIZE WE PAID $350
MILLION IN RANSOM LAST YEAR.
>>> WE'RE GETTING THE CLEAREST
PICTURE YET OF A HORRIFYING BOMB
ATTACK ON A SCHOOL IN
AFGHANISTAN.
A SERIES OF EXPLOSIONS SATURDAY
KILLED AT LEAST 53 PEOPLE AND
WOUNDED MORE THAN 150.
OFFICIALS SAY MOST OF THE
VICTIMS WERE SCHOOL GIRLS.
CHARLIE D'AGATA VISITED A
HOSPITAL IN KABUL WHERE SOME OF
THE YOUNG VICTIMS ARE BEING
TREATED.
CHARLIE, GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
IT TAKES A LOT TO SHOCK THIS
COUNTRY, BUT WHAT HAPPENED OVER
THE WEEKEND TOOK CRUELTY TO A
WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
WE'D JUST COME BACK FROM THE
HOSPITAL.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO SEE IS HARD TO WATCH.
WITH HER EXTENSIVE INTERNAL
INJURIES, DOCTORS AREN'T SURE
WHETHER 14-YEAR-OLD MERRIAM IS
GOING TO MAKE IT.
THEY KNOW THAT 18-YEAR-OLD
HABIBA WILL NOT.
BY FATE ALONE, SANAB HAPPENED TO
BE FURTHER BACK FROM CLASSMATES
WHO DIED ON THE SPOT.
"THE EXPLOSION FELT LIKE IT CAME
FROM THE GROUND AND THE SKY,"
THE 13-YEAR-OLD SAID, "AND I
STARTED RUNNING."
SHE
SHEN THEN NOTICED SHE WAS
BLEEDING.
SHE TOLD US SHE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY SOMEONE WOULD
WANT TO KILL HER.
"I THINK THEY JUST DON'T WANT US
TO STUDY," SHE SAID.
ON SUNDAY, PARENTS LAID THOSE
CHILDREN WHO DIDN'T SURVIVE TO
REST.
SENT TO SCHOOL IN SEARCH OF A
BETTER LIFE IN THE HOPE OF A
BRIGHTER FUTURE, DREAMS NOW
BURIED ALONG WITH THEIR
DAUGHTERS.
THE INTERIOR MINISTRY TOLD US A
MASSIVE CAR BOMB RIGHT OUTSIDE
THE GATES WAS FOLLOWED BY TWO
MORE EXPLOSIONS FROM DEVICES
PLANTED ON THE STREET.
A VICIOUS ATTACK DESIGNED TO
KILL OR MAIM AS MANY CHILDREN AS
POSSIBLE RIGHT AFTER THE BELL
RANG, JUST AS SCHOOL GIRLS COME
RUSHING.
AMERICAN TROOPS ARE HEADING
HOME.
AFGHAN FORCES ARE ALREADY
OVERWHELMED TRYING TO PUSH BACK
MILITANTS ON THE BATTLEFIELD
WHILE KEEPING CIVILIANS SAFE AT
HOME.
ZABAB DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
TO HER FRIENDS, AND SHE'S
DETERMINED TO RETURN TO SCHOOL
WHEN SHE CAN.
YOU WON'T BE AFRAID.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
"NO, IF I GET SCARED, THEY'LL
HIT US AGAIN," SHE SAID, "THEN I
WON'T BE ABLE TO STUDY."
THE TALIBAN SAY THEY'RE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ATTACK.
ISIS HAS A HISTORY OF BOMBINGS
IN THE AREA.
THE TALIBAN SAY THEY'RE
DECLARING A CEASE-FIRE,
THREE-DAY CEASE-FIRE, THAT
STARTS WITH THE MUSLIM HOLIDAY
LATER THIS WEEK